okay a very good guy without a gun
stopped a shooting at a Waffle House
restaurant in the Nashville Tennessee
area yesterday a reportedly completely
nude and subsequently only partially
nude 29 year old suspect the white guy
killed four people yesterday at a Waffle
House eventually fleeing naked
eventually finding a pair of pants at
his home and then going on the run and
still as of right now a major manhunt
going on in Tennessee in that Nashville
area looking for the alleged shooter
it's unclear what the motive was but we
do know quite a bit about the shooter we
know that he was previously arrested by
Secret Service for trespassing on white
house grounds he wanted to speak to
President Trump he describes himself as
a sovereign citizen one of those extreme
right-wing movements that is tracked by
groups like the anti-defamation league
and the Southern Poverty Law Center we
don't know exactly what his motive was
in this shooting but we do know that 29
year-old James Shaw ambushed the gunman
after initially hiding in a bathroom at
the Waffle House when the shooter
briefly paused and was sort of looking
at his assault rifle who knows how many
lives were saved by that action and as
Shaw described it he was not doing this
for other people he said straight up I
was thinking of myself I was thinking of
my daughter and basically realizing that
he was in a bathroom with no way to
really get out and that he was going to
try to interrupt this massacre in
progress being carried out by the 20 29
year-old shooter so he rushed the gunman
wrestled away the assault rifle the
gunman fled and James Shaw actually did
get grazed by a bullet on his elbow
while he was grappling with the gunman
shooter has still not been found again
known to police he had his guns seized
at one point although interestingly
after his firearms authorization was
revoked and four of his weapons were
seized authorities later gave those
weapons back to his dad who admits that
he ultimately gave the
weapons back to the eventual shooter
absolutely horrible and I've gotten a
few email saying hey David there's a
racial angle here there's a bad white
guy sovereign citizen with a gun who
shot up a place and then you've got a
black guy who wrestled the weapon away
from him and it seems to be a far less
interesting story to corporate media
than when a brown or black guy is the
one shooting white people I don't know
if that's true I genuinely am unsure I
know that there has been corporate media
coverage of this CNN interviewed mr.
Shaw at least a couple of times I think
there's no doubt that I mean we got no
tweet from Trump asking even for
thoughts and prayers which is already a
totally flaccid thing that we talked
about so in a sense it has gotten less
attention it's still early we don't know
if this guy was targeting any particular
group of people by going to this
particular establishment very late at
night or early in the morning we just
don't know yet I don't know if I can say
at this point that the story is getting
less attention because of the racial
element right I don't know either and
certainly that does matter to some
extent I'm surprised we didn't see a
tweet from Trump saying that Shaw did
what I would have done with his horse
rush the shooter even though I don't
have a weapon yeah and I think the guy
is a hero even though he says that he's
not which is which shooting was the one
where Trump said he would have done that
oh that was Parkland that was the
Parkland okay it's hard to remember
because Trump's had so many faux pas
Zinn responding to different terrorist
incidents and shootings that it's hard
to even keep track of it the shooter I
mean he's already being written off as a
lone nut he was naked after all but that
is a frequent thing we see from the
pro-gun right that when it is one of
these white guys who clearly how stable
can you be if you even attempt a mass
shooting they immediately say oh mental
illness is the problem this was a lone
nut or whatever but listen whether he
had drug problems or psychological
problems or whatever he was known to law
enforcement and the second Amendment
rights that he was able to exercise
are costing lives that's the reality and
I also want to point to something else
here another day
another horrible shooting but we need to
look at the broader context and
according to gun violence archive.org
there were 67 shootings not this past
week not this weekend yesterday Sunday
April 22nd the day of this Waffle House
shooting there were 67 other shootings
not all leading to deaths some just
leading to injuries this is just one of
them and I think that that's why when we
hear about one particular story we tell
the story it's it's a relevant story
every single one of these stories as a
tragedy but there were 66 other
shootings you probably didn't hear about
yeah I guess when you put it in that
context it does seem like this got a bit
of media attention yeah four people were
killed I mean it's not like 10 or 12 and
I guess the details are a bit
interesting so that's why the media
focused on it yeah so I guess it depends
on how you look at it yes yes it
certainly does and of course remember
that with how we define mass shootings
in the United States I believe it's that
unless three people three or four with
four four not including the shooter are
shot it's not even considered a mass
shooting so even when we look yesterday
at the number of mass shootings that
took place numerous I don't have the
number in front of me but this is how
bad the problem is and of course we hear
the exact same non solutions from the
gun fetishist right ranging from the
problem is merely mental health and not
access to guns - guns don't kill people
people kill people which is of course a
totally farcical distraction from the
realities of this problem in the short
term hopefully they catch this guy and a
couple law enforcement analysts saying
if he's even still alive this is someone
ripe for sort of taking their own life
whether or not the police are in hot
pursuit or maybe a few hours behind and
hopefully no more destruction and
carnage comes as a result of this guy we
will discuss it more tomorrow I'm sure
and several discussions going on about
this on our reddit discussion forum at
david pakman.com
komm /r e d di t quick break back after
this today's program is sponsored in
part by movements new sunglass line yeah
those are the watch guys I'm still
wearing my MV emt movement watch but now
they are also offering really great
sunglasses I actually wore my movement
sunglasses throughout my entire trip to
California last week driving all the way
up from LA to San Francisco very very
sunny out there we're not used to it in
Massachusetts but needless to say the
sunglasses really helped and some of you
know I have a long and beleaguered
history with sunglasses I bought like
hundred and fifty dollar pairs of
sunglasses before only to lose them the
same day while golfing and at the same
time when I buy really cheap sunglasses
they're just not very good and that's
why I like the movement glasses they're
not plastic they're actually made from
acetate lots of styles to choose from
classic round aviator mirrored they're
also available polarized and it all
starts at just 70 bucks
these are officially now my go-to
sunglasses and they did really really
well I tested them in the field last
week extensively and best of all finding
the perfect pair is risk-free with free
shipping and free returns you can get
15% off today free shipping free returns
by going to MVM t-dot-com slash Pakman
you already know movement because of how
they've revolutionize the watch industry
and I've spoken about that before now is
the time to check out their sunglasses
go to MVM t.com slash Pakman that's PA
KMA n join the movement